llegamos a nuestra sección de revista de
prensa en directo américa está conmigo
en el estudio rosa pérez más de eu rosa
bienvenida o mejor dicho bienvenido yo
de vuelta a este programa más rosa ya
estamos a martes hoy se cumplen tres
meses del inicio de la guerra en ucrania
vamos a abrir como siempre entonces esta
revista de prensa con la portada del
wall street journal the washington post
y también de lemont buenos días raúl y
bienvenido de nuevo
exactamente vemos que sin embargo pocos
medios no destacan esta fecha no estos
tres meses de invasión rusa de ucrania
pero nos centramos en algunos que sí lo
hacen empezamos por el francés lo mont
que destaca lecciones precisamente de
estos tres meses de guerra dice material
enfrentamiento entrenamiento comando a
pesar de que hay algunas las diferencias
entre los dos ejércitos dice cada vez la
batalla es más simétrica por otro lado
dice que este conflicto disipa la
fantasía de una guerra relámpago como se
podía creer al principio y vuelve a
subrayar un poco la importancia del
armamento clásico y de los flujos de
aprovisionamiento
destaca la importancia de la batalla por
la información y el relato por otro lado
vamos con el 'washington post' que aquí
en un lado destaca la sentencia a cadena
perpetua a este joven soldado ucra a ese
ruso por crímenes de guerra en ucrania
no una co de una condena que puede ser
más bien simbólica sobre todo si se
tiene en cuenta que él dijo que estaba
obedeciendo órdenes y terminamos con el
wall street journal que dice entre los
soldados y los civiles aumenta el número
de muertos y destaca las cifras que dio
un oficial ucraniano en el forum de
davos en que dijo que habría unos
4.600 civiles fallecidos y unos entre
2.500 y 3.000 soldados
ucranianos desde el inicio de la
invasión y vemos que esta pieza está
acompañada por la foto de un funeral de
un soldado ucraniano en kharkiv y
precisamente para enlazar con el tema
que vamos a comentar ahora vemos aquí en
este lateral también baiden promete
defensa protección militar
porque entonces se ha vuelto toda una
polémica rosa con estas declaraciones
del presidente de eeuu joe biden
sobre taiwán bien exactamente no estas
declaraciones son sobre todo polémicas
marc a beijing y por eso hemos querido
ver cómo tratan este comentario el
'global times' este medio chino tan
alineado con el partido comunista y
básicamente destaca esta cita de byd
hernández que eeuu intervendría
militarmente si china continental toma
la isla de taiwán por la fuerza y
también las palabras de fum yo quisiera
el primer ministro japonés ya que byd en
pronunció estas palabras en japón dijo
los intentos unilaterales de cambiar el
status quo por la fuerza como en ucrania
nunca deben tolerarse en el indo
pacífico y básicamente lo que argumenta
el 'global times' es que tanto a estados
unidos como a japón les interesa
desplegar lo que el 'global times' llama
una batalla cognitiva que es básicamente
comparar la situación ante la invasión
rusa de
ucrania con la potencia la ocupación
militar de china y taiwán para crear una
imagen hostil de china en la región del
indo pacífico y así eeuu reforzar sus
alianzas militares y de seguridad en la
región como puede ser la quad o la ocu
oa japón por ejemplo a aumentar su
potencial militar y también su peso
regional así el rosa y cerramos esta
revista de prensa con la revista 'time'
que ayer publicó su lista de las 100
personas más influyentes del mundo de
quiénes estamos hablando quién está
liderando esta lista tan esperada de más
rosa pues a raúl
como cabía esperar precisamente joe
biden y xi jinping así como vladimir
putin o el presidente también ucraniano
volodymyr de lentes que están entre las
a 100 personas a que considera las más
influyentes del mundo también
encontramos a ursula von der leyen la
presidente de la comisión europea pero
también a allup sol el canciller alemán
pero como decía al inicio también muchos
rostros de nuestra región y es que en la
categoría líderes encontramos en portada
no encabezando esta lista a mía mottley
la primera ministra de barbados que en
su mandato ha llevado a precisamente
barbados que era digamos una monarquía
porque todavía digamos su jefe de estado
era la reina isabel la segunda la reina
del reino unido ya se convirtió en 2021
en una república gracias al liderazgo de
mía mottley también encontramos al
presidente de chile gabriel boric y por
otro lado en a artistas por ejemplo
encontramos a ariana de bossi la que
ganó el oscar pues mejor actriz de
reparto por su papel en una website
stories se convirtió así en la segunda
latina en ganar un oscar en innovadores
encontramos por ejemplo a nombres que
hemos mencionado mucho en nuestros
informativos como derrick palmer y cris
smalls que han fundado el primer
sindicato de amazon también al
colombiano deivis david vélez perdón el
fundador de new bank oa los científicos
que terminaron la descodificación del
genoma humano también encontramos a tim
cook el director ejecutivo de apple oa
dmitri murátov en la premio nobel de la
paz y el director del medio ruso
independiente nóvaya gazeta y para no
quedarnos sin mencionar a las dos
colombianas cristina villarreal
velázquez y ana cristina gonzález vélez
las al líderes de causa justa esta
organización que llevó ante la corte
constitucional de colombia la
despenalización del aborto que
finalmente no está despenalizado en el
país hasta la semana 24 también francis
joven la informante de facebook o sonia
bajar al líder indígena brasileño que me
estaba bolívar selenski estabas hendaya
bueno un pocotón de personalidades 100%
influyentes claro que sí pues las
conocemos ya son muy familiares para
nosotros rosa muchísimas gracias
entonces como siempre por esta revista
de prensa nos vemos mañana con más
información pasamos a saludar a dos de
nuestras invitadas del día